[Music]
hey what's up guys welcome back to my
youtube channel and on this video we are
going to be diving deep into deal
sourcing and you're going to be learning
exactly step by step how to find
investors find deals and bring the two
together making a big fat fee now this
is going to be an interview i'm going to
be interviewing two very young guys 20
and 21 years old who are making 15
000 pounds a month
i mean damn like that's a salary for
that's an annual salary for some people
they're making a month simply from
finding deals and passing them on to
investors extremely successful in deal
sourcing the property guys welcome to my
house thanks for coming down thanks for
having me thanks a lot so firstly how do
you guys meet and how long have you guys
been in property
well we we've we're in school together
so
we've known each other since you're
about five years old um obviously left
school and then ollie was saying to me
all the time we got to get into property
showing
you to me all the time
and
i think we made the jump in august
winter when's your house discovery day
and then that's the future discovery day
into a deep discovery of deals
yeah
great so how did you find about property
like where where did it kind of come
from we've kind of been interested in
investing as we're growing up kind of
looking at how to make money that sort
of thing we always know we want to be
kind of successful and earn a lot and
yeah just looking at your youtube
channel probably from years ago and just
keep i kept watching it how many years
you've been watching the channel
probably about
three four years wow so you were
literally a teenager yeah watching the
channel and yourself as well yeah and uh
we met when you were like 20 years old
yeah that's it yeah 20.
and and and you came down to my house on
a discovery day
and joined the academy yeah during the
day on that day yeah yeah come down
learn a bit about it
learned learned about the academy made a
little plan of what we was going to do
how did you get the money for the for
the property investors academy well we
we were working previously so it was
just from saving up over a couple of
years just out of sixth form right and
just pretty much spent it all on the
academy
nice and what were you working as prior
to getting into property so i was
working in trade i was a painter and
also worked at a gym as well doing like
seven days a week working so the hustle
was there um
and then pretty much from
from then it's a couple months in in the
academy and then we just i dropped mine
um
still at the gym for a little bit but
yeah just went full time yeah and you
full-time now as well probably full-time
as well yeah and what were you doing
prior what was your job i am i do strong
man competitions so i was doing that and
i was also a personal trainer and i've
got like an online coaching company so
you want to be successful in property
you decide that you're going to go all
in you're young you've got energy you're
hustlers why did you choose the strategy
packaging and selling deals and what is
deal selling and why did you choose that
strategy so it just seems so lucrative
just there's so much opportunity to make
a lot of money fast as well there's
obviously a lot of strategies in
property that are long-term wealth
builders that take a lot of time to make
money but deal selling was obviously the
quickest and
yeah essentially we just jumped into it
um
obviously if anyone doesn't know deal
sourcing is finding basically investment
deals for investors packaging it up
getting offer accepted getting the best
possible deal and then just passing it
on for a fee for ourselves there's a lot
of misconceptions around deal selling as
well um and there's also a lot of
misconceptions just around property in
general like people's people will see
your story and see how within a matter
of months you're making so much money
and they'll be like no no property takes
years to but it's like well it depends
on what strategy you're doing and i said
i say this at the very beginning on the
academy it's like look guys
if you want to grow long-term wealth and
you want to build up a pot of wealth
then you're going to have to do things
like buy refurbished refinance going
into development commercial conversions
and that is very slow that's going to
take a long time to build up wealth but
if you're wanting to get quick
money it's not going to be passive it's
going to be bloody hard work you have to
roll your sleeves up but if you want to
make quick money then you can do deal
packaging you can do rent to rent and
then the money that you make you can
start putting into your own deals and
that's what you guys have been doing um
ridiculously successful
i mean what do you think what do you
think separates a successful deal saucer
from the ones that just watch a few
youtube videos have a bash and fire
what's separate successful and
unsuccessful i think it's kind of like
the education really the education and
the mindset because
some people yeah like you say just watch
youtube videos learn a little bit about
property and then just try sell deals
but they don't know all of the
background information
they don't know how to do proper due
diligence they don't know really how to
sell a deal how to cover themselves the
legal side of it all that sort of thing
is it's really the education to be
honest which is what we're going to try
and condense and bring out as much of
that education that you and and put it
into this one video for people watching
on youtube so let's start from the
beginning you want to be a deal seller
what's the very first steps if you were
starting again from scratch and you just
like i've got no investors list i've got
no money i've got no nothing i just want
to get started i've got no deals on the
table
what what's the first obviously aside
from getting educated assuming you've
got that knowledge what's the first
steps that you're going to do
i think the first step is just telling
everyone what you do because people need
to know what you're doing to be
successful you can't just keep it to
yourself you can't just try and go under
the cover people have to know and that's
the main thing we've found is just
telling everyone even just going getting
your hair cut just tell people what you
do you don't know who you're going to
meet come on you've not had a haircut
i'm soon no shaving off but yeah yeah
but i only met someone the other day at
tesco just just got chatting and now
we're speaking to them properly about
things it's just any anyone just have a
conversation they don't know what they
could bring to you tell the world that
you're a property investor yeah
that's nice and i think as well
sometimes i found that as well i did
some of my early deals with some of my
family members and i'm not from a
wealthy family but but just by telling
people you don't know something like oh
actually i know someone that's got a bit
of money i know someone oh this person's
selling the house and because you're
telling the world that you're a property
investor suddenly that's when
things start to come to you okay so you
tell everyone that you're a property
investor it lands on deaf ears
the barber in the hairdresser doesn't
care
then we'll just keep going we found yeah
just keep going but we found what we
were missing is kind of like a brand so
as deal sources we decided to um we
learnt from you we need to build our
brand um make people know who we are
more so we started pushing things out on
social media yeah um so we started using
tik tok instagram facebook we've just
made a youtube channel and really um
yeah what's it called the property guys
i'm one of the first subscribers man so
brand you guys went for the brand the
property guys what did you choose and
you're not you're you're your names i'm
ollie and this is james so why did you
choose to be known as the property guys
we just wanted to we just wanted to be
set aside from other people rather than
just being kind of generic want to just
have our own personal brand we just kind
of went for it on the day we're like
come on we're going to rebrand what
should we call it it's pretty quick to
be honest with you
just on the spot just came to us you
both agreed on it yeah okay so first
thing is tell everyone what you do
second thing is create a brand
and what do you what does a brand mean
what is it how can someone just create a
brand
well it takes time for starters it's not
just that it happens overnight something
you build on
but it's some it's for people to relate
so
if people see you see you as your name
it might not leave as big a big of an
impact on them rather than seeing the
property guys for example rather than
just being known as jamie and ali the
deal sources and i guess you're just
putting out content so one of the things
that i've seen you guys doing so well
and i've got huge admiration for what
you've built is everything you do you're
documenting it even when you're going
out you're viewing properties you're
putting you're documenting what you're
doing you're putting stuff out there
which is really good for your journey
and you can look back on it and you can
see your growth but also it goes back to
telling the world what you do you're not
just telling the people that you know
but you're also now putting it out there
on the platform you guys have got deals
from tick tocks tell me the story of
that of that guy that actually ticked up
what happened yeah so we just we got a
message on tick tock one day um a guy's
father he come down ill and um so he
wanted to sell some of his portfolio so
he wanted to sell one of his buy-to-lets
and he messaged us he just said do you
think you'd be able to sell it and um we
spoke to some of our investors we
managed to sell it within a couple of
hours nice and how much did you get paid
for that in total what was the amount
that you profit that you got we charged
we charged him two grand for that deal
so someone got in touch with everyone
from tick tock and said you're the
property guys
i've got someone my dad whatever selling
their house it's not on with an agent
yet it's off market could you sell it
and you sold an investor without even
using an estate agent what's the
difference between an estate agent and a
deal sourcer a deal source is trying to
get like the lowest possible price for
their investor yes and the estate
agent's trying to get the best possible
price for the seller yeah so it's a bit
of a difference there um
in in that respect
that's huge though yeah because if if
you go to an estate agent and you say
hey i'm looking for deals
they're thinking about their
clients which is all of their sellers
and they're trying to get the highest
price so they're trying to drive you up
yeah whereas when you're a deal seller
and your your client is the investor so
you're trying to drive the price down
and the difference between knocking 10
20 grand off a property pays for your
finder's fee exactly yeah which means
the next question
how do you know what to charge
as a finder's fee so if you're selling a
deal how do you work out what to charge
and what's fair yeah it's it's something
it's hard there's no set answer but we
kind of say on average you're looking at
one to two percent of the house price
but depending on the deal say you've got
a deal that could make a hundred grand
you might want to charge more it kind of
it does just depend but on average
you're probably looking at around three
four grand for a basic deal really okay
so three or four grand about average
one to two percent of the purchase price
so if you're buying a house for two
hundred thousand you might expect to pay
around one to two percent of that
what kind of deals
are investors really looking for because
i know this is different for different
people but um some deal sources tend to
sell
um you know buy to let some sell went to
rents some might say option agreements
or development deals what is it that you
found
really investors are actually looking
for in 2022 yeah well essentially
everyone wants a brr right now and
especially
hmo or sa because obviously rents of
rents really intrigues people and that's
just using the same concept but buying
one so doing up making hmo hmr
especially everyone wants one just a
bris hmo obviously commercial valuation
and it's just gonna be worth so much
more what is it that made you guys
decide not to really focus on selling
rent to rents renter rents are very time
consuming um they they can sometimes get
a little bit messy as well they they do
take a lot of work to get a renter in
whereas using that time we kind of we
thought in our interest it's kind of
better to put it elsewhere
to maximize our returns and you were
saying to me that you think there's a
lot of
deal sources that
i selling went to rent but actually
they've got a landlord that's agreed to
a company left but it might not
necessarily be a good rent-to-rent deal
yeah i think people get too excited with
rent to rent as well they'll they'll
finally get a company that agrees a
company let and then they'll think oh
great i've got i've got an amazing rent
to rent when really when you look at the
figures the returns aren't aren't always
great so yeah and the really good rental
events i mean if you found a really good
rental rent that's like normally down
controlling the property you probably
just keep eating yeah why'd you sell it
yeah you know so and everyone's got
their niche and there's no right or
wrong um but you your niche is really
looking for buy refurbished refinance
ideally with also combined html service
accommodation so that not only are you
putting out all or most of your money
but also you're recycling your money but
also you've got a really high lucrative
rent so if anyone doesn't know um
what does bio refurbish refinance mean
what does it look like and what would be
a typical example i mean tell me what
was the last deal you sold so
essentially br is buying a property that
is preferably below market value in
quite a bad state doing a big refurb on
it to add the value get to his new value
and then refinance on a loans value
mortgage 75
which means you can get basically pull
all the money you've put into the
project back out so essentially you've
got the property for free in a
roundabout way and then you're just
living off the passive income with the
rent
and that's why that's why it's really
that's why people love it because it is
like getting a property for free
which makes it great
and in terms of the last day it was it
was our last it was a conversion wasn't
it yeah it was a it was a three-bed
terrace house um there was planning on
it to convert it to a two-bed a two-bed
flat and a studio flat and we actually
spoke with the council on that deal we
managed to get some grants for it well
some they were payable back but
we managed to get 40 grand grants for it
so that we could do the refurb and they
were only payable back when you go to
sell it so
our investors were refinancing the
property and then they was going to just
take the money off of it monthly so it
was great for them wow and that's the
thing that's what you're paying a deal
source for you're paying a deal sourcer
to do all that research to line
everything to package it you're not just
selling
um a right move link you know and you
could do you could sell a lead you could
say oh i've been tipped off that this
property is gonna the the seller's gonna
accept a really good offer
but that would be maybe give me a
hundred quid for a tip-off but what
you're saying is not a tip-off you're
selling a package deal where you've had
an offer put forward an offer accepted
you've got a power team lined up you've
done all the research what happens when
deals go bad what would happen if
someone
reserved a deal
maybe even paid you a finder's fee and
then the the deal fell out of bed or the
seller got higher off or elsewhere what
do you do when things go wrong because
things do go wrong yeah they do and
you've just got to be up front to to
people and just not try and get your way
out of it things happen they do happen
um
obviously the contracts are in place you
just got to refund them and just explain
the situation really it's happened a few
times a few times we think it might it
may have happened it was close to
happening then it then it came back and
we sold the deal again it definitely
does happen you do that's why you have
the contracts like um you you'd probably
offer a replacement property so you'd go
find a new one but yeah you just have to
be upfront and honest with them and
speak to the investor and i think that's
one of the things that most people don't
prepare for properly they don't that you
can look at what happens if everything
goes right
but you also need to think well hang on
if things go wrong if if the investor
decides to pull it out what happens what
happens if the
seller pulls out what happens if the
property if you've missed something as a
deal sorcerer because as a deal source
so it's not your job to
pay for surveys on the house and that's
the investors job your job is to
package and present an opportunity and
then you pass it to the investor who
ultimately needs to take responsibility
for you know getting their own services
getting their own surveys and searches
on the house but sometimes things happen
there's there's a structural problem
that was missed or there's um you know
they've
um plastered over some really serious
damp and you wouldn't be able to tell by
looking at it and then when the survey
comes up and you realize oh my goodness
and then of course that's a problem so
what would you do in that situation what
would you do if you sold an investor a
deal they were really happy and it was a
nice little you know cheap
fixer-upper and then it turned out that
the house was riddled in damp it was
going to cost
tens of thousands of pounds to fix and
it had just been all covered up by the
seller and the survey came back and
there was there was there was there was
a big problem and suddenly the property
was not profitable anymore it wasn't
viable the investors really upset they
call you up
i know this happens
what
what's the solution what happens is
reputation is important and keeping
those strong relationships are important
so we would we would just offer a
replacement so we'd go we'd go out and
find a like for like and that's all in
the contract so that when the investor
pays you your fee they know they've got
a 14 day call and off period
if anything goes wrong after that
there's all the different ifs and buts
so the investor knows up front
what so you're not arguing basically
about it how important do you think
expectations are when you're selling a
deal you've got to make sure they're
clear at the start um everyone's got
wants to know what's going to happen and
yeah
it's it's important as well to like
you've got the 14 day calling off period
after they've paid you not to spend that
money in any way because if anything
does happen you need to give them a
refund yeah so things like that are
important definitely it's the money's in
the bank but it's not in the bank if you
know what i mean yeah you've got to be
careful and you guys are registered with
the property ombudsman
you've got anti-money laundering in
place you've got all the contracts
insurances um all set up to protect you
from if things do go wrong it's
definitely important to be covered
obviously it doesn't things don't go
wrong a lot and
a lot of time you won't need to use the
insurances but they need to be there for
if anything does happen let's talk
fingers now then because you guys are
absolutely steaming ahead so
what you know you recently did a post
saying um how
we we're making 15 grand a month from
deal sourcing and everyone went crazy
and i was like right guys you're on the
academy come and talk um is that true 15
grand a month yeah yeah last month feels
a little bit more than that what was it
last month just over 16. wow
wow and
and that's literally just from packaging
and selling deals just just that's it
yeah packaging and selling deals we took
on bespoke clients as well people don't
have bespoke services where you work
more closely with the investor
understanding their specific needs and
you go and look for certain properties
for them so we took two of them on also
got a project oversea which was that
conversion we're overseeing that project
when it starts okay so you're also doing
project management services so they can
be totally hands off yeah that's what we
that's kind of the best it's the upsell
yeah which is not a bad thing because
because it's like anything it's like if
you go to mcdonald's and you say you
know hey can i get um could i get a
hamburger and they'll say would you like
fries with that
what you're doing is you're saying hey
we've also got this service and we've
got that service so smart yeah so what
are you spending the money on
well we're kind of at the moment we're
putting a lot of it back into the
business a lot of promotions um we're
getting a video done like proper video
for one of our properties that we source
that's smart they're pointing back into
the business we're investors too like
we've taken advantage of the crypto diff
at the moment what's some bitcoin yeah
yeah good we're kind of just building up
a big pool of cash yeah so that we can
do our own projects and that's kind of
what we're looking into now we've found
like a really nice brr project where you
can have all the money out and quite a
lot of profit on top of it as well see i
remember speaking to you guys at the
freedom forum intents at the beginning
of the academy and we talk about when
you deal selling you need four things
you need deals
you need investors
you need skills to how to sell actually
make it happen and run the business and
you need contracts yeah if you've got
those four things there's no reason why
you can't make we say three to five
grand a month you've gone a little bit
above that and making like 15 grand or
more above um however once you learn how
to package and sell deals and you've got
those four things what you can then do
is you can then with you can you've got
download you've got deals investors
contracts and skills
you can find a deal find an investor
instead of selling it to them you can
join venture with them which means that
instead of them paying you three four
grand and gathering the deal when you've
got a really juicy deal you're gonna say
to the investor hey would you like to
put the money in we'll project manage it
we'll take care of it and we'll go 50 50
on the profits
that would be the obvious logical next
step for you now you've been in this
game for three six months and you're
selling a lot of deals what do you feel
about that yeah i feel exactly that
that's what you're basically yeah yeah
yeah it's got to be yeah yeah you've got
to be progressing in yeah so yeah that's
that is the next step so you're gonna
start building your own portfolio joint
venturing trying to build our wealth
that way yeah definitely and and that's
crazy because most people will save up
loads of money
working on a job and then put that put
the savings into a house
you're working smart making 15 grand a
month
but even so
you don't have to put that profit into
your own deals you can joint venture
yeah use other people's money yeah it's
going to be in their interest as well
because they haven't got the time to do
this
we've got the knowledge and the time so
we run everything and then they take the
profit on top of it building an empire
so what's what's the strongest reason
that you're doing this well there's a
few reasons isn't there um
just to prove we can do it um
be the best be to the top and kind of be
set aside from what the usual is really
just to go get a job go to university do
the usual thing
um
just want to be different and unique in
ourselves really
want to be yeah financially free we want
to have the ability to do whatever we
want literally whatever we want yeah and
for me like i want i want the money to
be able to push my sport like my
strongman sport and push that as far as
i can
so yeah so basically
you want to have the money to have the
time to pursue your passion and um
you're about to cook your hair soon as
well bro yeah talk to me about that
yeah we've been been growing it for two
years got a bit fed up with it recently
to be honest with you um obviously look
a bit more presentable in the property
game as well um
see i'm shaving off a charity um
calm campaign against living miserably
which is men's mental health which is
obviously a big issue in today and we've
taken steps to kind of resolve that so
yeah shaving it 27th february two weeks
time
and yeah nice congrats and why is that
charity important to you
well it's
to be honest with you something a lot of
people go through and they don't people
they don't speak about it i've gone for
it myself and you realize that there's a
lot more people going for it than you
think
[Music]
and it is hard to speak about and that's
why we need to start bringing more
awareness to it kind of get the word out
make people speak about it it's harder
for men to speak about it people know
that so
just trying to raise awareness how do
you feel that property getting into
property has impacted you know you talk
about mental health and stuff like that
um has it had any effect on your
day-to-day lives or how you think or
what what's it it's on on a personal
level how is it how's it affected your
lives yeah it certainly affected them
positive positively as there's there's
always something to wake up to there's
always a reason to wake up now there's
never not
there's always something going on with
us so
there's always a goal in mind always
busy doing something yeah and you've got
that passion term that you're working
towards yeah because for us like we're
nowhere near where we want to be
eventually so
it's just we're just starting really um
we've yeah so you know you've got that
goal you know you've got that passion
you every day you're moving forward to
something
and you're not sitting there dwelling
about anything you're just pushing
forward yeah yeah i think i think we
also know
we are only limits as well so there's
nothing stopping us in that respect
we're not limited by anyone else in it
in a way so in a job you might be
limited by certain factors but it's only
us yeah we control us so you control how
much money you earn exactly yeah you
control what you do when you get up what
does an average day look like for you
well
to be honest when we started it was a
bit hard to get into routine obviously
because we've been used to a job and
kind of working that way
but nowadays we're we're up and at them
about eight a.m in the mornings if we're
in the office we're there like eight or
five kind of working until the agents
are shut so you guys have your own
office now well we say office it's in in
my house we converted a room into like a
big office room nice
nice it's i like how it's serious though
that's their office yeah you see the
environment that's that's key that is
key you need that workspace so do you
spend more time in the office on the
phone to invest as an agent or on the
road actually viewing houses
probably a mixture of both to be honest
we do we do it in sections so we when
we've got deals on the go we'll be
working on them packaging and we might
have to go see certain meet people at
certain properties working on those
specific deals but um yeah like tomorrow
we're going down to the midlands for the
next three days to um we've got some
bespoke clients that have they want
deals up there so we're staying up there
for a few days till till friday just
looking for deals every day we're going
to be in and out of agents ringing
agents it must be a pretty fun life yeah
it is it's different to a normal just
office nine-to-five job you guys treat
it so serious it's like you're not
thinking oh
i'm gonna do deal selling and hope to
make three grand a month without
actually doing anything you guys are
like no we're going to take the business
we're going to learn it we'll join the
academy you're all the training programs
and on the mentoring calls and sessions
and mastermind groups which is also good
for networking of course yeah definitely
and then you're out bang doing it 15 16
grand a month crazy do you ever ever
have to pinch yourself how much money
you are you're making i mean how much
are we making before to now where is the
average about
i was making three to three and a half a
month three two three off grand yeah so
you did quite well before i was i was
working seven days a week right all the
time oh yeah you're on two jobs yeah so
yeah that's always there yeah what about
yourself what were you earning before
you got into property probably about um
four or five okay so you're again
earning quite well yeah but it's just
constant always working and you're not
building wealth you're just you're just
getting that money
but now you're earning like three times
that
and doing what you love with also
opportunities to scale up and invest in
your own projects yeah
what kind of what kind of deals are you
generally i know you said brr but like
where are you looking in the country
how do you know if a deal is good or bad
you know talk to me about how you
actually find these deals yeah well as
we said we've got a couple bespoke
clients at the moment up in the west
midlands that's where where we are
tomorrow and until friday obviously
we're based in in essex hertfordshire so
where we are we have had a few deals
here but it's not as good for obviously
as you know for property and returns um
so yeah so west midlands obviously wales
as well and a lot of people are looking
right up north towards kind of
manchester liverpool and in newcastle
durham those kind of areas yeah um
there's a lot of a lot of good
properties up there
but as you know the market's hot so
things get snapped up straight away so
that's why we're kind of booking places
up there so we can do it we can find a
property view it that day and make an
offer and get it accepted straight away
and also i know you get a lot of
off-market deals yeah best tip for
getting an off-market deal building
relationships with estate agents really
right so they're from estate agents but
they'll pass them you before they even
get to right move yeah that's it and
that comes from them just knowing who
you are right yeah yeah exactly that's
because we we bought a property
obviously sold as a deal from an estate
agent um where we're local to and now
they're always on us because they know
we're going to complete on a property
yes they're always like look we've got
these properties going on
the best way to build a relationship
with an estate agent is to buy from them
once
you buy from them you're a customer then
yeah yeah yeah they know you're the real
deal they know you're gonna you know
you're gonna complete so yeah yeah so
biggest piece of advice for someone
starting out
before we wrap up go
for me i would say i said it before but
get yourself out there take advantage of
social media it is such a big part of
today's society and how everything's
going into adaptive times
and yeah social media get yourself out
there love it it's hard to keep up but
yeah you need to do it yeah yeah i'd say
knowledge just
learn everything once you've mastered
everything and then just go out there
and do it love it are you glad that you
took his advice and and and actually
came to some of the
programs i don't know maybe
no yeah of course yeah no well it's
life-changing
yeah it took a while man so well done
dragging him down yeah and it's crazy
how life goes
it's been great working with you guys
for the last sort of three six months
and i'm excited about what's to come so
uh big respect and uh keep on keep on
winning oh thank you thanks a lot samuel
cheers man well done so there we have it
folks that's how you package and sell
deals and make 15 000 pounds a month if
you want to do the same and you want to
come down to the property investors
crash course tickets on the house right
now they're very limited but if you want
to grab your free ticket or leave a link
in the description get down i'd love to
meet you in person i do an interview
like this every single week with some of
my students you can check out the whole
playlist up here subscribe and i'll see
you down below at the property investors
crash course peace
[Music]
you